Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to use an AI to fly
into this photo. And we will see how
much better this technique has become
in just one year. It will be insanity.
Yes, in a previous video, we explored an insane
idea: what if we could take just one photograph
of a landscape, and then, we would fly into this
photo like a bird. Of course, that is a big ask,
because to be able to do this, we would need to
invent at least 3 things. One is image inpainting.
Look, when we start flying, the regions between
the trees are missing. We need to generate those.
Two, information is also missing not just within,
but around the photo. This is a huge problem,
because completely new regions should
also appear that are beyond the image.
This means that we also need
to perform image outpainting,
creating these new regions from scratch.
Continuing the image, if you will.
And three, as we fly closer to these new regions,
we will be looking at fewer and fewer pixels
and from closer and closer, which means…this.
For this, we would need super resolution - in
goes a coarse image or video, and this AI-based
method is tasked with…this! Yes. This is not
science fiction. This is super resolution,
where the AI starts out from noise and
synthesizes crisp details onto the image.
So, last year, scientists at Google
created an amazing AI that was able
to learn and fuse all these three
techniques together, to create this.
Wow, so this is possible after all. Well, hold on
to your papers, because it is not only possible,
but the followup paper is already here, we are
now one more paper down the line, in less than
a year later! I know you’re itching to see
it, me too, so let’s compare them together!
These methods will all start from the same point,
and oh my, look how quickly they deviate. The two
earlier methods quickly break down, and this
is the work that we talked about a few weeks
ago. This is clearly much better, however, as
every single one of you Fellow Scholars can see,
it lacks temporal coherence. What is that?
Well, this means that the AI does not have
a long-term vision of what it wishes to do, and
barely remembers what it did just a few frames
ago. As a result, these landscapes start morphing
into something completely different very quickly.
And now, you know what’s coming, so hold onto
your papers and let's look at the new technique!
My goodness, I love it! So much
improvement in just a year. Now,
everyone can see that these are also not perfect,
but this kind of improvement just one more
paper down the line is nothing short of amazing.
Especially that it doesn’t only have better
quality. No-no, it can do even more. It offers
us more control too! Now we can turn the camera
around and whenever we see something interesting,
we can decide which direction we wish to go.
And the result is that now, we can create and
also control these beautiful, long aerial
videos where after the first few frames,
every single thing is synthesized by an AI.
How cool is that? What a time to be alive!
And, it doesn’t stop there. It gets even better.
If you have been holding on to your papers so far,
now squeeze that paper, because this new AI
synthesizes these videos…without ever having
seen one. That’s right, it had never seen a video.
The previous work was trained on drone videos,
but training this one only requires
a collection of single photographs.
Multiple views and the camera position
are not required. That is insanity. This
AI is so much smarter than the previous
one that was published just a year ago,
and it requires training data that is much
easier to produce at the same time. And,
I wonder what we will be capable of just
two more papers down the line. So cool!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!